Wer schon mal so einen pilz trip mit magic mushrooms
Hatte weiß dass die drogen ähnliche halluzinationen auslösen wie lsd
Also es wirklich in sich haben und außerdem nicht ganz ungefährlich sind schon seit 60 jahren ist die substanz die dafür
Verantwortlich ist bekannt sie loszugehen doch was hat es mit dem halluzinogen
Stoff aus sich ein forschungsteam hat jetzt das geheimnis
Um die zauber politik gelöst wie genau sie also funktionieren warum sie so gefährlich sind und warum ihr wirkstoff
Auch als medizin genutzt werden könnte in zukunft jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Schon vor etwa achtung
4000 jahren haben die urvölker in mittelamerika wohl mit halluzinogenen pilzen
experimentiert ja sogar verehrt und diese so genannten zauber pilze zu
spirituellen zwecken genutzt denn die substanzen der magic mushrooms haben tatsächlich
Bewusstseinserweiternde effekte auf den körper man kann sehr scharf sehen und alles wird von
Extremen lichtern überzogen es gibt studien zu diesem magic mushrooms die hinweise darauf geben dass die
Persönlichkeits verändernde wirkung der drogen auch ein jahr nach der einnahme noch messbar ist und genau deswegen ist das
Image der freizeit droge zu recht zweifelhaft und der name sauber pilz der ist viel zu positiv denn das
regelmäßige einnahmen der sogenannten zauberkiste kann schlimme gesundheitliche konsequenzen
forschungsteams beschäftigen sich seit etwa den fünfziger jahren mit den pilzen
Denn ihr könnt es euch denken ihre wirkung könnte auch in der medizin und pharmakologie
eingesetzt werden und von großem nutzen sein natürlich nur unter ärztlicher aufsicht
den entscheidenden wirkstoff der magic mushrooms isolierte ein schweizer chemiker schon vor 60 jahren der name der substanz psilocybin
Seitdem ist auch seine chemische struktur klar genauso wie seine wirkungsweise. Im körper diese ähnelt in zügen der des glückshormons
serotonin
Nerven botenstoff der auf natürliche art und weise in unserem gehirn produziert wird und dort beispielsweise für gute laune
Ausgeglichenheit und erholsamen schlaf sorgt damit bin ich zum beispiel ganz gut gesegnet bei einnahme der magic mushrooms wandelt der körper den
halluzinogen stopp
in seiner aktiven form um
psycho ziehen dieses bildet dann in unserem gehirn tatsächlich an die andockstelle die eigentlich für das glückshormon
serotonin gedacht ist absolut zu bieten dann ähnliche
halluzinationen wie lsd aus auch wenn der rausch der pilze meist etwas kürzer an
Studien aus den 60er jahren beschreiben zwar bereits mögliche ansätze wie dieses besondere moleküle in den pilzen gebildet werden könnte
Doch wie genau es entsteht war bislang unbekannt gesucht. Also enzyme die die pilze als werkzeug benutzen um die biosynthese
des psycho zu wiens zu bewerkstelligen derjenige stoff der die halluzinationen und
Bewusstseinsveränderung hervorruft dies ist jetzt endlich einem forschungsteam aus jena gelungen er kennt es noch
Aus dem chemieunterricht der synthese weg solcher komplexer molekülstruktur ist wahnsinnig kompliziert
Und erfolgt in mehreren schritten den forscherinnen und forschern gelang es tatsächlich diese komplizierte synthese
Im labor nachzustellen dafür war es erst einmal notwendig die entsprechenden werkzeuge der pilze. Also die enzyme
herzustellen dies konnten sie tatsächlich mit hilfe
genmanipulierter bakterien und pilzkulturen umsetzen und damit konnten sie die herstellung von psilocybin
im labor rekonstruieren ganz ohne pilz zellen das ist ein riesenfortschritt
zudem haben sie damit gezeigt dass die biosynthese in einer anderen reihenfolge
Abläuft als bislang vermutet dieser erfolg ist tatsächlich nicht ganz ohne denn es bringt die forschungsteams einen schritt näher an ihr ziel
Das hochwirksame hallo, zu gene molekül, im labor bereit zu stellen um es dann auch
Im pharmazeutischen bereich einsetzen so können eben als medizin denn erste klinische studien zeigen bereits dass psycho zudem über gewisse
Heilkräfte verfügt wenn es unter medizinischer kontrolle eingesetzt wird es könnte patienten mit lebensbedrohlichen
krankheiten wie krebs die angst nehmen oder auch depressionen
Mindern wenn es also
medikamente wie psycho zu bienen gibt
Dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier bei klick zum wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt
Mir hier also ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit die zehn gefährlichsten drogen bezogen auf ihre wirkung auf die gesamte menschheit sehr
aufschlussreiches video also drauf klicken und mehr über drogen wissen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran